.
HERSCHEL WALKER, I CAN'T WAIT
FOR THAT DEBATE.
ALSO TONIGHT FLORIDA AUTHORITIES
ARE PREPARING RESIDENTS FOR THE
EXPECTED ARRIVAL OF HURRICANE
IAN.
EXPECTING TO STRIKE FLORIDA THE
MIDDLE OF THIS WEEK.
HERE IS THE FLORIDA SENATOR
MARCO RUBIO.
THIS LOOKS SEVERE.
THERE ARE EVACUATIONS AROUND
TAMPA.
WHAT IS GOING ON
BEHIND-THE-SCENES?
>> WELL, THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT
FLORIDA HAS A LOT OF EXPERIENCE
DOING THIS UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE
WE HAD A LOT OF STORMS.
A FEW YEARS AGO I WENT TO THE
NATIONAL HURRICANE CENTER AND
SAID WHAT IS THE WORST POSSIBLE
STORM HITTING OUR STATE?
THEY DESCRIBED WHAT WE ARE
FACING RIGHT NOW.
A POWERFUL HURRICANE STALLED OFF
THE COAST.
DOESN'T HAVE TO MAKE LANDFALL
OVER FLORIDA.
STALLS AND PUSHING WATER INTO
THE TAMPA BAY REGION AND THE
WESTERN PART OF THE STATE.
5 TO 10 FOOT STORM SURGE WHICH
ARE NOT SURVIVABLE.
YOU CAN SHELTER AGAINST THE WIND
BUT YOU CAN'T SHELTER AGAINST
WATER.
WHEN THE TIDE GETS THAT HIGH,
YOU CAN'T SURVIVE.
THE ONLY WAY TO AVOID DIEING IS
TO LEAVE.
THEY KNOW THE AREAS MOST
VULNERABLE.
IT WILL TAKE TIME TO GET YOU TO
GO.
I HOPE PEOPLE WILL FOLLOW THE
ORDERS.
THIS IS A LIFE THREATENING
THING.
THERE IS NO WAY TO RIDE IT OUT.
>> Sean: I KNOW PEOPLE BELIEVE
IN LIBERTY AND FREEDOM.
THEY DON'T WANT TO LEAVE THEIR
HOUSE.
INCONVENIENT.
I WOULD ASK OUR LISTENERS TO
PROTECT YOURSELF AND YOUR
FAMILY.
TAKE IT SERIOUSLY.
THE WORST CASE SCENARIO YOU TOOK
A DRIVE YOU DIDN'T NEED TO TAKE.
CRAVER ELECTION.
-- YOUR ELECTION.
YOU ARE SUPPORTED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN THE STATE OF
FLORIDA BECAUSE OF YOUR GREAT
WORK AS SENATOR.
EVEN THOUGH YOUR OPPONENT CLAIMS
TO HAVE THE SUPPORT OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT, SHE DOESN'T.
>> SHE WOULD BE THE MOST LIBERAL
SENATOR FLORIDA HAS EVER HAD.
VOTES WITH PELOSI 100% OF THE
TIME.
SHE WAS A POLICE OFFICER AND
WENT TO WASHINGTON AND TURNED
HER BACK ON THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
THAT MAKES IT WORSE BECAUSE SHE
KNOWS BETTER.
SHE WANTS TO BE PICKED AS THE
VICE-PRESIDENT OF A PARTY TAKEN
OVER BY RADICAL LEFTISTS.
HE TURNED HER BACK ON POLICE
OFFICERS AND VOTED FOR BILLS
THAT ALLOW YOU TO SUE POLICE
OFFICERS INDIVIDUALLY.
ALMOST EVERY SUFFER IN FLORIDA,
57 ENDORSED BY CAMPAIGN BECAUSE
THEY SAW THAT AND KNOW HER
RECORD IN CONGRESS.
SHE DOESN'T TELL PEOPLE SHE'S
BEEN IN CONGRESS FOR 6 YEARS
BECAUSE SHE NEVER GOT ANYTHING
DONE AND VOTED AGAINST FLORIDA'S
INTEREST AND AGAINST COMMON
SENSE AND BEHALF OF THE RADICAL
LEFT 100% OF THE TIME.
>> Sean: IN A LOT OF THESE
RACES, IT'S THE BIGGEST CHOICE
ELECTION EVER.
WHAT IS HER VISION VERSUS YOUR
VISION SO THE PEOPLE OF FLORIDA
CAN BE CLEAR WHEN THEY GO INTO
THE VOTING BOOTH TO VOTE?
>> WELL, HER VISION IS WHATEVER
THEY TELL HER THE VISION NEEDS
TO BE ON THE FAR LEFT.
WHAT VISION IS THAT?
A VISION THAT WILL DESTROY THIS
COUNTRY.
VOTING IN FAVOR OF ALLOWING
SCHOOLS TO INDOCTRINATE CHILDREN
AND TURN BOYS INTO GIRLS AND
ALLOWING THE COUNTRY TO BE
OVERRUN.
OUR BORDER, THIS IS
A CATASTROPHE.
IF ANYBODY CRITICIZES YOU, YOU
CALL PEOPLE RACISTISTS OR
FASCISTS.
THEY ARE ONE VOTE AWAY IN THE
SENATE FROM PASSING ANYTHING
THEY WANT -- THEY WILL GET RID
OF THE FILIBUSTER AND PACK THE
SUPREME COURT AND THEY WILL
SPEND 4 TRILLION DOLLARS.
THEY WILL DESTROY AMERICA IN WE
DON'T STOP THEM.
>> Sean: WITH YOUR RACE LIKE SO
MANY SENATE RACES THAT ARE SO
CRITICAL.
IF REPUBLICANS CAN GET THE HOUSE
AND THE SENATE, IT WOULD STOP
RIGHT IN ITS TRACK THIS RADICAL
SOCIALIST AGENDA.
IF WE WIN IN 2024 WE CAN G